[Musique]
il
depuis que nous l'étudions l'origine de
l'homme n'est pas clair alors que
l'évolution de tout être vivant suit les
lois de la nature
l'évolution humaine présente des
anomalies
[Musique]
en 1860 darwin théorise l'évolution
naturelle mais sur l'homme cette théorie
est démenti par le fameux chaînon
manquant
aujourd'hui les progrès scientifiques
porte à 4 les anomalies de l'évolution
humaine sans pour autant savoir les
expliquer une réponse bien qu'incroyable
est donné par les anciens textes sacrés
du monde entier et aucun d'eux ne parle
d'évolution naturelle de l'homme au
contraire ils citent tous une évolution
piloter
les anciens textes
tu mets rien chinois indiens égyptien et
grec cite la création de l'homme comme
l'oeuvre de plusieurs êtres non
terrestre qu'ils appellent dieu
les anciens textes hébreu et chrétiens
affirment que l'homme est le produit
d'un ajustement de choses existantes et
que un ou plusieurs dieux ont réalisé
une opération chirurgicale avec
anesthésie prise de chair et suture sur
adam pour obtenir rêve
[Musique]
l'islam affirme que l'homme est une
nouvelle créature terrestre apparu du
rien créé par un seul lieu
[Musique]
la science moderne a établi que la vie
sur la terre est apparu il y a quatre
milliards d'années et qu'après deux
grandes extinctions en as elle a enfin
générer les plantes et les animaux
[Musique]
kylie à 60 millions d'années naissent
des primates et qu'il y a 5 millions
d'années apparaît le premier hominidé
l'australopithèque
le volume de son cerveau est de 450
centimètres cube comme les singes il
mesure 130 cm il vit dans les arbres et
alterne cadres rhdp dit et bipédie
[Musique]
il y à 2,5 millions d'années se produit
une première anomalie
[Musique]
une espèce d'australopithèque passe de
48 chromosomes à 46 et devient une
nouvelle créature l'homo habilis comment
at elle fait les chromosomes
transmettent les informations génétiques
aux cellules mais s'il change soudain de
nombreux le résultat est une aberration
chromosomique
après avoir réussi cette manipulation
génétique il faudrait en outre clooney
ensuite un grand nombre de mâle et deux
femelles fertiles pour permettre la
survie de l'espèce qui pouvait à cette
époque réalisé en masse ces
manipulations génétiques que les
scientifiques modernes connaissent à
peine
[Musique]
des extraterrestres le veda le plus
ancien des livres adien site
400000 race humanoïde existantes dans la
voie lactée dont une douzaine mais jadis
venus visiter la terre à maintes
reprises
[Musique]
l'ésotérisme affirme que plusieurs êtres
existe dans l'univers et qu'ils sont
semblables aux humains puisque les lois
sont les mêmes partout dans la création
[Musique]
les plus anciens de ces êtres ont
coutume de greffer leur adn sur les
hominidés de différentes planètes dans
le but d'obtenir l'union des humanoïdes
dans une unique conscience
peut-être que des mâles et des femelles
australopithèques ont été l'objet de
cette coutume est donc génétiquement
muté en humain dont la première marche
et l'homo habilis
[Musique]
le fait est que l'homo habilis survie au
changement de la structure chromosomique
et devient le premier représentant de
l'humanité sa taille reste à 130 cm mais
son volume cérébral augmente de 450 à
600 centimètres cubes
c'est dans sa structure osseuse et
nasale change
ils marchent exclusivement debout et
fabrique des galets taillés pour se
défendre des prédateurs et dépecer les
animaux il y à un million d'années
certains homo habilis quittent l'afrique
pour l'europe le moyen-orient la géorgie
la chine l'indonésie
comment ont-ils fait
[Musique]
à cette époque quelques centaines
d'hommes munis d armes et de pierres qui
se mettent d'accord par grognements et
gestes pour entreprendre un voyage
intercontinental à pied ne peut pas
arriver si loin et sur plusieurs coins
du monde en même temps sauf s'ils sont
portés comme nos éleveurs portent leur
bétail sur les camions les bateaux et
parfois même par avion
une fois arrivés les homo habilis mute
devenant une nouvelle créature l'homo
erectus dont le volume crânien passe en
un seul bon de 600 à 850 centimètres
cubes selon les lois de la nature
c'est une aberration génétique un
parisseaux évolutif a besoin de
centaines de millions d'années pour
aboutir
sauf si cette manipulation est effectué
en laboratoire en plusieurs étapes
[Musique]
le fait est que l'homo erectus s'en sort
très bien
ils maîtrisent le feu
vit paisiblement pendant un million et
demi d'années et se répand avec succès
en asie en afrique et en europe
l'homo erectus n'a aucune raison de
changer
et pourtant un autre incroyable sont
évolutifs va le modifier il y a deux
cent mille ans les régions à évolution
accélérée du cerveau de l'homo erectus
augmente soudainement et énormément leur
efficacité
alors que dans les cerveaux des animaux
ces régions restent stables pour des
centaines de millions d'années pour
parvenir à un tel résultat dans un temps
si court
il n'y a que le laboratoire le cerveau
de l'homo erectus double presque passant
de 850 à 1000 450 centimètres cube
il devient ainsi une nouvelle espèce
l'homo sapiens
cependant la tête de son foetus est trop
grande pour sortir des organes de
reproduction pour sauvegarder l'espèce
humaine
l'accouchement est alors anticipé à neuf
des 18 mois qui serait nécessaire mais
la mortalité est fréquente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la science n'explique pas ce passage à
normale entre l'homo erectus et l'homo
sapiens
[Musique]
laissons cette tâche aux sumériens
d'après leurs écrits des humanoïdes
géants venus d'ailleurs les belliqueux
hanouna qui après avoir colonisé mars et
la lune s'installe en mésopotamie où ils
bâtissent et ridules et au zimbabwe où
ils exploitent les gisements d'or
ayant besoin de main d'oeuvre pour les
excavations les hanouna qui capturent
une femelle d'homo erectus combine
génétiquement son adn avec l'adn hanouna
qui est il y a deux cent mille ans
toujours d'après les sumériens cette
femelle génère l'homo sapiens
une nouvelle espèce d'homme apte à
comprendre les ordres et à obéir
[Musique]
toutefois nu
l'homo sapiens n'est adapté à aucun
environnement
il n'a plus de gros poêle et de défense
tandis que ses cheveux poussent temps
continue s'accrochant partout cela
complique la survie dans la nature mais
les homo sapiens sont des spécialistes
en fabrication d'outils il se coupe les
cheveux se socialise et gesticulant pour
se faire comprendre
grom des mots
[Musique]
il y à environ 60 milles ans survient la
4e anomalies dans l'évolution de la
lignée humaine
[Musique]
une révolution inconcevable dans la
nature donne
l'homo sapiens de la pensée symbolique
[Musique]
pour la première fois des êtres vivants
sorte des limites du présent propre à
tout organisme est extrait des symboles
mentaux qui les amène à conceptualiser
l'avenir l'infini et le transcendant
la pensée symbolique que ne servant à
rien si elles n'expriment pas des
concepts le larynx et le palais de
l'homme s'adapte alors il parle
maintenant aisément et bien que sauvage
ils discutent de troc et de sentiments
il est devenu l'homme
notre ancêtre à nous le premier rue main
l'unique être vivant à s'étudier soi
même et à s'interroger sur le
fonctionnement du monde cette fois ci il
n'y a pas eu d'élargissement cérébrale
il y a eu un mécanisme génétique qui
s'est déclenché dans le cerveau humain
est là reformater activant la pensée
symbolique
[Musique]
cette très forte accélération donner aux
gènes du développement céphalique n'est
possible qu'en laboratoire par la mise
en oeuvre de l'ingéniérie génétique
[Musique]
l'homme peuplent le monde avec succès
quand il y a dix mille ans une grosse
météorite tombe sur la terre provoquant
un déluge kinois tout être vivant y
compris les hommes
faute d'autres données sur ce désastre
nous prenons au mot les écrits sumériens
il raconte genki un chef hanouna qui
alertent du déluge
un homme génétiquement amélioré swiss ou
draps afin qu'ils construisent une arche
pour sauvegarder le patrimoine génétique
de sa famille des animaux et des plantes
produit à eric quand le déluge sa chair
il ne reste que quelques humains échappé
sur les montagnes et la famille 2,8
soudera qui se mélange entre eux et
repeuplent la terre c'est alors que les
à nouna qui se partagent le monde et ses
habitants
[Musique]
les hanouna qui se combattent d'entre
eux pour des questions de territoire et
comme ils sont très avancées en
technologie
il n'est pas difficile pour eux de
capturer les hommes et de les forcer au
travail ou à la guerre les hommes
à cette époque sont aussi intelligents
que les hommes modernes
il s'intéresse au mystère de la mort et
aux amulettes magique mais ils sont
vêtus de peaux et bien qu'ils cuisent
les aliments ils se nourrissent à la
façon des animaux et vivent sans règles
et sans morale
[Musique]
les sumériens site l'éden un énorme
enclos bâti par les halles où naquit
entre l'arménie et la mer caspienne
c'est à cette époque et à ce même
endroit qu apparaissent soudainement les
premiers animaux domestiques
[Musique]
la brebis mutation chromosomiques du
mouflon sauvage du moyen-orient est
l'unique animal au monde aux plages qui
pousse en continu très utile pour
fabriquer des vêtements chauds en laine
le chien est la domestication du loup
orientale transformé en gardien
obéissant le cheval est la domestication
du tarp en orientale le boeuf est une
mutation du boss aux russes
[Musique]
parmi les végétaux le génome de
l'épeautre sauvage fusionnent
incroyablement avec le génome d'une
grameen assez comestibles et donne
naissance au blé cependant dans la
nature
s'il y a fusions le corps moeurs
sauf si cette modification génétique est
réalisée en laboratoire
[Musique]
c'est
l'éden est donc désormais un territoire
d'agriculture et d'élevage et comme cela
nécessite des travailleurs une tribu
d'homme tout entière est capturé et y
est transporté dans l'éden ces hommes et
ces femmes sont domestiqués afin
d'effectuer des travaux serviles et
deviennent une nouvelle race d'hommes
les adam it
les adam it ne peuvent pas sortir de
l'éden mais ils y vivent très bien
la nourriture est assurée tout autant
qu'un apprentissage culturel et
technologique considérable
sans parler de l'absence de danger or de
l'éden le monde est peuplé de fauves et
d'hommes sauvage
pourtant il y assimilant les adam it
sont chassés de l'éden ils descendent
alors le long de la mésopotamie
s'installe entre les fleuves tigre et
euphrate fonde le pays de sumer et grâce
aux savoirs acquis dans l'éden
il apporte aux natifs du jour au
lendemain une civilisation prête
fonctionnel et très avancé
[Musique]
les sumériens invente l'écriture
représentant les expressions phonétique
de la parole par des caractères
cunéiformes il invente l'école pour
l'instruction et le droit pour punir la
justice il réalise des calculs
compliqués en ingéniérie et sont les
premiers à utiliser les nombres se
montrant capable de résoudre des
équations algébriques de 3e degré en
astronomie
ils connaissent toutes les planètes de
notre système solaire y compris uranus
neptune et pluton qui ne furent
découvertes que le siècle dernier
c'est toujours les sumériens qui ont
inventé le calendrier divisant le jour
en 24 heures et leur en 60 minutes
ainsi la civilisation sumérienne
apparaît soudainement là où il n'y avait
que des huttes et l'histoire du monde
débute son aventure
[Musique]
aventure dont au fond nous ne
connaissons que les derniers cinq mille
ans mais l'homme existe bien depuis deux
millions et demi d'années
[Musique]